what do you have any goals I mean what
do you what's going on with like what do
you want to do out of life now or like
any New Perspective shift or like is
there a new Shane
Dawson like what do you what's changed
what do you want to do with your life
what do you have any purpose yeah I mean
my I mean my real my life life I uh
we're having a baby hopefully two or
three so we uh yeah we're doing that in
I mean she's the surrogate is being
implanted in a few weeks so that's
happening which I'm so excited about um
how much
legal red tape is there before that cuz
isn't it like a and the prices well that
okay that's the darkest part is pressing
purchase on a mother like it's like what
on a surrogate well so that's the other
thing I didn't know so egg donors this
might be boring sorry guys egg donors is
different so like the egg donor who is
the mother and then they they put your
sperm in the egg and then they put it in
a surrogate who has no like conect no
genetic yeah who sperm do they put in
there you or your husbands so we did
both of our sperm in I was saying so you
guys just do a double batch and then you
just mixed it together cook it all up
and well that's the other thing too cuz
I'm like well would I I mean I know what
I look like as a girl it's not great but
I'm like but do I want oh never mind I
was going to say something really dark
but yes so it it is wow you're showing
progress here thank you well I'm
thinking about my Future kid watching
this you know what I mean that changes
everything like if I would have known I
was going to have kids one day that
would have the internet that everything
stays there forever and then they can go
and be like Daddy what is this I never
would have done any of it I mean I don't
regret it I think everything happens for
a reason but um so yes we're cooking
them up um what do you mean by cooking
them
up I was going I was going along with
his mixing thing but you know like so
yeah they we have 12 potential children
I believe 12 six of mine six of his um
or do we have 24 sperm I don't remember
oh so you're saying there's there's a 12
eggs yeah and they can keep an egg
viable like in a freezer well that's the
other thing so the embryos so the number
kind of keeps going down it's like oh we
got 30 whatever eggs okay only this many
survived okay only this many sperms
attached so now we're left with 12 six
boys six girls six of mine six of his
and they're they're embryos and they're
frozen so they're like two weeks old
each which I didn't know two week old
like human baby right well well yeah and
now I'm thinking like I got to bring
them all because like what there's just
mean some frozen forever that are 2
weeks old like they're alive in my head
I don't know maybe that's Han Solo so
what you want to have all 12 no don't at
the same time no [__] Octomom
that that's the new Shane no uh that's
your new show the reality show
yeah thanks bad track records for for
those things um yeah no so I mean I
think we want to have three kids but now
now that we have 12 I don't know what to
do is just start giving them to people I
don't is that that's bad I can't do that
that auction button on your
website yeah I don't know yeah I don't
know so so there's that I mean but as
far as like career stuff um I've I just
really want to make um a horror movie
that's kind of my I have two scripts
written and one of them kind of fell
through in the last couple months so now
I'm kind of rerouting and trying to get
this one made but but yeah that's kind
of Michael but that's G I mean I'm more
like I'm not quite satisfied yet with
the the surrogate like that like and I'm
just interested the the uh it's very
common I think that that a surrogate
mother will you know after growing this
baby inside them have some attachment
and then like U you know get cold feet
or whatever and say I don't want to give
up the baby it's my baby right I I
wasn't aware of the baby inside them not
being genetically theirs that's a
different wrinkle but presumably they
still have some kind of attachment and
there's all kinds of legal paperwork
like uh you know
so what's the legal process like in in
uh establishing the agreement with the
surrogate and what's the
interpersonal uh kind of did do you
develop a relationship with them before
picking them right yeah it was wild we
started like a year and a half
ago actually no I think just a year ago
and um so first we had to pick the egg
donor and we instantly both of us knew
we didn't tell each other but we knew
the donor and then I said it and he said
it and we were like oh my God that's the
one so we picked her um why what about
her I don't know it was just like a
weird like God my sistere thing my
sister had a sperm donor she was
artificially
inseminated the the my niece who's such
a fan of yours and um what what struck
me about the process was that by the
time you make it through all of the
screening they've they've determined
that there is no like uh like no medical
problems to to worry about like going
through the whole family tree everybody
in the family tree is all healthy into
their like 80s like they're all like
college educated like there's just it's
just C it's almost like the Olympics of
being an impressive person that you have
to like you know by the time you become
a donor like you're just kind of
documented as being like just the
picture of health and and
accomplishment and so that that is
pretty impressive well the thing with
sperm donors too cuz my therapist she
was we were talking about it and uh she
had used sperm donor in the past and she
was like you know what's crazy is like
you know when you're picking the sperm
donor there's like levels like Financial
levels like okay if you pay an extra
$100 you can get a voice note from them
so you can hear their voice if you pay
another hundred they'll draw you a
picture I'm like this is the mostu it's
like only yeah it's crazy I'm like what
the [__] is this so it's bizarre I mean
the whole the whole process is extremely
depressing and amazing and it took a lot
of like
mental gymnastics to figure out how to
not get depressed about it but after
meeting both of them and really and the
surrogate yeah and getting you know um
their stories and why they're doing this
because that was my fear I'm like well
what if they how could they have the
baby and not want to keep it how is that
possible Right but the girl who's
donating the eggs she was born through
egg donors cuz her parents use them so
she had like a connection to that she's
done it once before and her whole thing
was she was like you know I would love
to be in some kind of you know I'd like
to be updated or be you know to I don't
want it to be a thing where I give my
eggs and I don't know anything after
that and I was like great cuz I want to
be able to tell our kids sounds like
entanglements sounds like strings
attached I got to deal with this
person I wanted that though because I I
want to be able to tell my kids one day
cuz you know listen I'm realistic about
it too and some people get mad when I
say this and by some people I mean
people in my family but I'm like I want
to be honest with my kid I know they're
going to see a commercial where there's
a mommy and they're going to be like why
don't I have a mommy and they're going
to have some issues with that they're
going to be sad about that and I want to
be able to explain it to them and also
you know when they're ready show them a
picture or you know I want I don't want
it to be this weird [__] up Seeker
that [__] them up that sounds like uh
egg donor is way different than sperm
donor because in the case of the sperm
donor it's uh you you can find out their
their whole family trees medical history
their whole family trees education
history like everything about them but
you cannot like legally you cannot um
get their name or you know like it's
it's sort of a right of passage for
adopted kids to go and track down their
biological parents you know like you
hear about it a lot and it's like a you
know it's a thing but in the case of of
uh someone who was artificially
inseminated with this donor sperm it is
0.0 there is no right of passage for my
niece to go and find her biological
father because it is like legally
precluded you definitely cannot get a
picture of of of the person well I also
now I'm thinking about it I really hope
I I don't want to offend anybody that
you know I don't want it to seem like if
you don't know who your father is or
your mom I'm sorry I didn't mean to say
it like that don't don't like don't
don't trip because I think that's just
natural you know
human consideration right yeah I mean
but it is yeah I mean with the surrogate
to so she's done this before and um I I
asked her like how do you because she
has kids of her own I'm like how do you
how do you explain this to your kid that
you have other babies that they don't
you know whatever and so she had like a
word for it like suros sister so like
you know she's very open with her
daughter and um I just want it to be
open I don't want it to be weird or like
secretive just because I my childhood
had a lot
of some secretive weird [__] and you
know I think that is in turn what made
me you know really delve into food and
[__] up a lot of things for me once
again everything happens for a reason so
I'm fine with it but you know I just
want to I don't know I'm just trying to
figure it out do you like shopping on
Amazon I do and good new news is sto's
butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get sto's
hot sauce for your butthole plus sto's
butthole destroyer and steo butt wipes
for your butthole it's the butthole
bundle available on Amazon right
now yeah dude